elle est racée nerveuse souple et agile
elle se soucie peu des rochers ornières
ou chemin difficile qui se présente sous
ses roues elle c'est la rente chaud le
tout nouveau modèle né de l'association
mettra think sceptique avant de mettre
le contact on devient rapidement
enthousiaste que ce soit sur route ou la
rente choses se révèle comme une
excellente berline ou sur les chemins
cahoteux du massif des maures
ce qui étonne le plus c'est la souplesse
de l'ensemble face à certains obstacles
on se pose des questions mais là rancho
passe et passe très bien grâce à ses
deux roues avant motrices issus de la
fourgonnette 11/100 vf2 la rancho est
équipée du moteur huit chevaux de l'a13
108 gt qui permet d'obtenir une
puissance et un couple important à bas
régime
la garde au sol de 21 cm 7 à l'avant et
de 26 cm à l'arrière permet quelques
fantaisies impensable avec une berline
ordinaire alors tout chemin tout terrain
ou break améliorée c'est une voiture
d'utilisation classique ordinaire
donnant les mêmes satisfactions qu'une
voiture de grande série
est ce qu'un acheteur en 1977 exige
d'une voiture c'est à dire un service
mais d'autre part on a voulu accroître
ses possibilités disons pour trouver un
terme qui nous paraît réaliste en faire
une
chemins possibles c'est à dire une
voiture qui peut s'évader des réseaux
classiques de circulation sans
rencontrer de grandes difficultés en
particulier parce qu'elle a des
pneumatiques de haute résistance et une
garde au sol importante
le terme de tout terrain ne s'y applique
pas il faut le dire et demandent des
véhicules très spécialisés qui sont
beaucoup plus coûteux qui consomment
beaucoup plus décent ça nous a paru un
point qui ne fallait pas franchi
compétitive la ronde chaud peut
s'enorgueillir de l'être moins de trente
six mille francs soit la moitié de la
plupart de ses concurrentes tout terrain
tout comme la consommation d'ailleurs
qui est celle d'une berline ordinaires
soit entre 9 et 10 litres selon la
vitesse les pneus de 185 sont montés en
série et lui assure une tenue de route
aussi sécurisante sur route que sur
chemin
la coque métal et polyester est
renforcée par un bouclier en fibre de
verre qui entoure le véhicule étonnant
aussi le volume intérieur banquette
rabattue on peut transporter 500 kg de
bagages plus 30 kg sur la petite galerie
située sur le toit de la cabine en
option la ronde chaud peut être équipés
notamment de deux projecteurs orientable
d'une protection inférieur pour une
utilisation continue en tout chemin d'un
treuil électrique à l'avant un crochet
de remorques et l'installation
électrique correspondantes sont livré en
série tout comme le pré équipement radio
et le pare brise feuilleté seul reproche
le passage aux places arrières difficile
mais un nouveau système est à l'étude
après la moto verte la voiture verte
elle sera disponible sur le marché début
juin et est d'ores et déjà certain que
les amateurs seront nombreux et ils ne
seront pas déçus
[Musique]